welcome back today we're going to talk about the
thyroid i have some interesting information i'm
going to try to keep this really really simple if
you have a thyroid problem this video is for you
i've done a lot of videos in the past
on the thyroid this one comes in at a
slightly different angle okay so we have two
different situations with the thyroid we have
a thyroid condition we have not enough hormones
it's called a hypothyroidism and then a condition
where you have too many hormones that's called
a hyper thyroidism okay now with a hypo 90
of the time it's going to be hashimoto's that's
an autoimmune issue with a hyper thyroid issue
80 of the time it's going to also be an autoimmune
condition called graves disease okay so that's
the first thing you need to know um most of
these conditions are autoimmune conditions so
they're really not thyroid as much as their immune
issues and so let's just kind of go through this
with a hypo okay not enough thyroid hormones
and we're talking primarily about hashimoto's
it occurs eight times more in women now with a
hyper graves um you also see almost eight it's
like 7.5 times more common women between the
ages of 40 and 60. okay so that's the first
clue another clue is that one of the triggers for
a hypo hashimoto's is that a woman who gives birth
in three to eight months postpartum past their
their birth has higher incidence of hashimoto's
so what does that tell us right there estrogen is
involved and we already know that estrogen blocks
the conversion from t4 to t3 now if we switch
over to graves there's a seven times higher
risk of developing this condition a year following
your delivery again involving estrogen so estrogen
apparently is a big trigger when you get a a total
t4 and a total t3 measured on your blood test
that is not the best test you should get a free
t4 and a free t3 test you're going to have more
accurate data now when we talk about tsh thyroid
stimulating hormone okay which by the way that
is not a thyroid hormone it's a pituitary hormone
your pituitary makes a lot of different hormones
and that's one of them it controls the thyroid
from above from somewhere in your brain a lot of
doctors will use the normal value of 0.4 to 5 as
being normal but there's some more credible data
that states that that normal value for
thyroid stimulating hormone should be 0.45
to 2.5 okay not all the way up to 5. that
would be a more of a normal range that i
would focus on so if it's above that then there's
a problem and also realize that the higher the
tsh goes now the next point i want to bring up
is the relationship between t4 and t3 t4 is a pre
thyroid hormone and then t3 is the active thyroid
hormone so it has to be converted and there's a
huge problem with a lot of people with the
conversion and so you need certain things to
help you convert which we'll get into in a second
but if you have a thyroid problem and you're on
synthroid you're taking t4 realize you're taking
the inactive version your body has to convert it
and what you may not realize is that 20 percent
of t3 is produced directly from your thyroid gland
and the rest is the t4 so if you're given t4 only
and not t3 you could be a bit shy on getting the
full benefit of the thyroid hormones thus the
reason why you still have these symptoms and the
other reason why you may have still have symptoms
and you're on synthroid is just simply because
they're treating a secondary problem or you have a
problem with the conversions so what would you do
if you have a hype o hashimoto situation here's
some ideas i would recommend taking selenium
zinc both of these help the conversion from t4
to t3 they're also very powerful antioxidants
and the inflammation that's generated from these
autoimmune conditions block the conversion these
cytokines block this conversion so this these
two will help reduce that inflammation and help
the convergence now vitamin d is just a given
vitamin d helps autoimmune conditions in general
and it's going to lower the inflammation seek help
would be beneficial not just with the iodine but
it also has selenium and zinc and a lot of the
other trace minerals and then purify bile salts
bile salts help convert t4 to t3 and so they
will increase more thyroid hormone production
and if you have a liver problem a fatty liver a
gallbladder problem thickened bile you're going to
be deficient in bile salts and that could be the
reason why you're not converting thyroid hormones
now let's shift over to graves vitamin d is
essential i would recommend if you're going to
take vitamin d for any autoimmune issue it should
be minimally fifteen thousand IUs twenty thousand
IUs up to forty thousand IUs or even more and
the next thing i'm gonna recommend is vitamin b1
why because b1 can lower your estrogen dominance
if you have a hyperthyroid condition one of the
things that happens is you use a lot of b1 and
so you're usually going to be very deficient
and you're also going to be deficient vitamin
d but you're going to be really deficient in b1
and if you're deficient in b1 you can have a lot
of the symptoms that will mimic a lot of other
conditions so you want to take bottom b1 in fact
i would probably take it with the hypo as well
but for hyper cases like graves you don't
want to take purify bile salts because
that's going to give you more thyroid
hormones it's going to help you convert more
you already have too much so you don't want to
take that all right so that's all i wanted to
communicate about the thyroid in this video thanks
for watching before you go if you have a question
about a product or you're new to keto and you want
to know how to begin keto or you're on keto and
you need a debug because it's not going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to help you
this is just for the people in the us hopefully in
the future we'll be able to answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below so
you can call and get some help you